AS WE GO TO
OUR NEXT GAME, ZOO CREWS.
ZOO CREWS.
THIS WEEK IN 1896, AN ITALIAN
INVENTOR NAMED GUGLIELMO MARCONI
FILED A PATENT FOR THE RADIO, OR
AS GUGLIELMO PROBABLY WOULD HAVE
SAID IT...
(ITALIAN ACCENT): "IT'S A-CALLED
THE RADIO."
"IT'S-A ME, MARIO."
"IT'S-A ME, GUGLIELMO."
ALL RIGHT, I THINK WE CAN ALL
AGREE THAT IN THE 100-PLUS YEARS
THAT FOLLOWED, THE HANDS-DOWN
GREATEST THING THAT RADIO HAS
GIVEN US IS... MORNING ZOO RADIO
DEEJAYS.
SO IN HONOR OF ALL THESE
GLORIOUS SHOCK JOCK TEAMS-- YOUR
BARRY AND THE BREETARD OR, HEY,
MARCONI AND THE MUNCH-- I WANT
YOU TO BUZZ IN WITH AS MANY
WACKY MORNING ZOO RADIO NAMES AS
YOU CAN IN 60 SECONDS.
AND BEGIN.
(BELL DINGS)
UH, GARY.
>> THE CAPTAIN AND SCHLEMIEL.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
ELI.
>> CHOCOLATE THUNDER AND THE
KLAN MAN.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
NIKKI GLASER.
>> WHITE MIKE AND THE BITCH.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH, POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
ELI.
HORNDOG PETE AND THE ROOFIE.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
NIKKI.
>> ETHNIC RICO AND AN OLD
BULLHORN.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS. POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
ELI.
>> UNCLE CREEPY AND TOUCHY
TAMMY.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
"ONE OF US IS GONNA TOUCH YOU."
NIKKI.
>> ROTTEN BALL BILLS AND AN OLD
A-ANTIQUE LAMP.
>> HARDWICK: OKAY...
(BUZZER SOUNDS)
>> NO. NO POINTS.